we are going to take our lives in our
own hands we are going to join together
and fight for what's right which is what
they're doing and they're doing it
freaking peacefully and they're doing it
all over the nation not just in alberta
not just in ottawa uh we've got some
some video of the convoy right here
let's take a look at that i mean it's
just look at that that is absolutely
extraordinary what they're doing those
are thousands of good people who are not
out there because they hate trans people
or have an irrational fear i should say
they have an irrational fear of trans
people and that's why they're out there
in the convoy that's literally what
trudeau said and tweeted they have an
illegitimate fear of muslims and that's
why they're out there they're white
supremacists
god these people the gall like what i
don't know what could have happened to
the human soul that could lead them to
that place but it's not just justin
trudeau who's soulless it really is not
you all know
my favorite lady over in dc
jen soccer
uh she's lying about what's happening up
in canada take a look
so truckers in canada last night shut
down the ambassador bridge which carries
about a quarter of us canada
trading goods
so what's the administration's response
uh to this action and what steps are
being taken to ensure the free flow of
goods and also
any preventative steps being taken to
address a possible blockade on the
michigan side of that bridge well let me
first start by saying i know there's
been some suggestion not by reporters
necessarily at all but that
this congestion is related to the
vaccine requirements it's not i mean i
i'm saying i'm going to get to the
protests but the protests uh going on
across canada which have spread to a
bridge or leading to sporadic congestion
and blockages
all right first off i want to give her
credit because she's actually dressed
like a witch and it's like a little on
the nose so good for you saki um now
interestingly as per what she said there
about the truckers and what's happening
there's this guy up in canada who
actually completely disagrees with her
i think one of the things
we all understand is just how frustrated
everyone is um we're all frustrated
we're all sick and tired of restrictions
of of mandates of having to to make
sacrifices of not being able to do the
things we love
i can understand frustrations with
mandates but mandates are the way to
avoid further restrictions or having to
be restricted as people get vaccinated
as canadians have gotten vaccinated
we've been able to get through things
and this team is going to stay focused
on doing exactly that
we're all so frustrated nobody know how
this thing happened we don't know we
mandates are the way to freedom well i
don't know who did this who's in charge
around here i just have nice hair and i
wear nice socks and people think that
i'm a really nice guy even though i'm an
evil [ __ ] okay so i don't know how any
of this happened
here's trudeau saying the complete
opposite individuals
are trying to blockade
our economy
our democracy
and our fellow citizens daily lives
it has to stop
freaking individuals
is there anything worse than individuals
you know peacefully doing stuff and
saying that we're not going to bow to
the king is there anything worse
cleaning up garbage shoveling snow
helping old people across the street is
there anything worse than individuals
well it's not just justin trudeau i i
like that justin trudeau impression what
do you think it's pretty good i
don't know how this happened it was i
was somebody told me that something was
happening i you know i talk like this so
it seems like i'm not evil or that i
don't have bad intentions but i'm really
a frighteningly horrible person um
it's not just justin trudeau though who
is lying flat out lying about the
intentions and the motives and the
actual reality on the ground that the
truckers are doing
uh it's all of our mainstream media
we've got quite a compilation for you
sedition insurrection a threat to
democracy this city is under siege they
are now calling it an occupation an
alarming situation there in ottawa the
police chief is calling it a nationwide
insurrection driven by madness this is
kind of our insurrection by air horn
moment it's i think it's part of the
globalization of trumpism canadians know
where i stand there hasn't been as much
violence as some had perhaps projected
but that does not necessarily mean that
it has been peaceful reports of severe
vandalism and criminal behavior streets
are clogged the honking is incessant and
deafening this pandemic has sucked
for all canadians residents that i have
spoken to who say they feel terrorized
intimidated residents say they feel like
hostages residents in that area say that
they are being held hostage that this
freedom has essentially this freedom
convoy as they call it has essentially
imposed a lockdown on them some
protesters harassed a soup kitchen these
anti-vaxxers actually took food from the
mouths of the homeless hungry yeah
because they were they're so put upon
there have not been any violent
outbursts however horns have been
honking for 12 to 21 hours a night the
small fringe minority
of people who are on their way to ottawa
or who are
holding unacceptable
views that they are expressing many of
them are holding confederate flags i've
heard there's q anon supporters in the
crowd we've seen swastikas we've seen
the confederate flag we've seen a flags
with justin trudeau our prime minister
in a noose uh lots of donald trump flags
as well people chanting let's go brandon
it is actually one of the rare times in
history you're going to see swastikas
and yellow stars at the same protest
what is
a human
what is a human being like what are
those people doing
i can accept that a certain amount of
them are brainwashed and i can accept
that a certain amount of them just want
a gig that it's nice to be on tv
they put makeup on you you know it's
nice they do your hair they might give
you clothes
i do my own hair they do whack me with
powder i pick out my own clothes
um but these people have sold their
souls i don't know what how else can you
describe human beings
who lie
as their main ethos the main driver of
what they do is to lie about people
i i don't know how else you can describe
it
they want there to be violence you could
that one woman out there hasn't been on
violence really and you know there's
swastikas and there's we don't see any
images of any of this they showed one
confederate flag there's trump signs
everywhere haven't seen those but that
doesn't necessarily mean it's something
bad
these people are evil and just juxtapose
that with how they treated the actually
violent riots that we had all over the
united states of america for the last
two years except you know it was odd
i have to look into this why did all of
those race riots stop the second that
joe biden became president did we solve
racism did we solve the policing thing
and all the systemic stuff and all that
stuff do we solve all that or could it
be that that's actually the democrats
and the media working together to
destroy trump and then they you know
they stop it when they need it to be
stopped and you know then their guy was
in power
crazy right